hello everyone welcome back for another
Comic-Con 2022 interview with the team
behind paper girls you guys know this I
love your show I'm so excited for you
congratulations thank you so much all
right so where to even begin with this
uh Brian I know you have had a good deal
of series experience at this point
adaptation experience what is something
from show to show that has stayed
consistent in terms of your process and
then what is something about paper girls
in particular that you know stood out as
a unique challenge that you had to
tackle a different way wow I I guess
with each show I have learned that it's
always you have to find the right people
and then you have to trust them and you
have to let them know uh this is we
don't want the karaoke version of our
book we don't want you to just do beat
for beat what we have already done cliff
and I poured so much of ourself into
this book we want you to pour some of
yourself into it and that's been true of
every adaptation I've worked on but I
think what's new here is working with
these young performers and I was sure
you know and part of the reason we did
the comic is it's like oh it's really
hard to do film and television with 12
year old uh people so we can do it as a
comic but if it's ever become the show
they're gonna get 16 17 year olds are
going to age them up and the fact that
they were able to find these
extraordinary young people who fully
embody our characters and are so
amazingly talented that's not just
something new for me I think that's
something kind of new for for television
so it's awesome my entire conversation
with them is probably just going to be
me gushing over there
exceptional all right Chris for you now
I'm full blown obsessed with Halton
Catch Fire and my brain just can't
compute why you didn't get another show
running gig immediately after that came
to a close so what was the process like
that led you to Paper Girls oh uh I mean
haunted Catch Fire is such a special
show that was six years of my life I did
it with Chris Cantwell my dear friend uh
and the truth is you know many things
have to come together for a show to
happen we got our heart broken a couple
times after Hall and it wasn't until
paper girls came around that you know
the right thing shaped up again that we
could really put ourselves into and so I
do think this is in some ways the
spiritual error to some of the things we
are playing with in that series uh
certainly it starts in the 80s as well
but but it's awesome to be able to
approach new territory I I think with
some of the lessons learned from that
show so so it's been awesome to kind of
stretch our wings and can you give us an
example of a specific lesson learned
that you actually applied to paper girls
but then also even with all your
experience what's something about what
it took to show her on paper girl is
that caught you by surprise 100 I think
the most important thing I learned on
Halt and Catch Fire is you have to let
this story speak to you uh there's a
story you set out to write and then
there's the story that wants to happen
and on this show you know we showed up
with these wonderful characters that we
took from the comics but then we cast
these wonderful actresses and they want
to be a little different they want to
bring things to the characters that
maybe aren't envisioned and you need to
listen to that and go with it and just
as we did that on Halt and let that show
go to places we never envisioned when we
set out I think each of these girls has
changed the fundamental four characters
of the comics in a in a way I just found
so beautiful and I can take no credit
for all right so kind of jumping off of
that Cliff for you even though you
worked on the source material here what
is something about even your own work
that was even stronger than you ever
realized when it was brought to screen
it's like even though you made it when
you saw it in this particular format
through this Medium you're like whoa
like that is way more powerful than I
ever could have imagined it would be
yeah I don't know if there are like
specific instances of it it's kind of
like the whole project has the same
heart and feel that we put into the
comic book and and that's so
um incredibly I'm so grateful for that
um you know the writers the whole team
and the actresses they really I think uh
you know accepted the story really
assimilated it and and want to kind of
put out this new version of it that's
expanded and you know in many ways just
you know just uh just an incredible New
Vision for it I hate asking this
question because it makes me feel greedy
because season one hasn't even come out
but again I love your show I'm gonna
want more when you start a process like
this do you need to map out a series
overview for yourselves before you even
jump into season one of the show yeah I
mean I think it's that Hold On Loosely
but don't let go I think we know some
places we'd like to get but we are open
to better ideas winning out we
absolutely have a direction planned for
a second season and I just hope that
God's smile on us and we get to do it I
say this a lot I'm a big believer in
manifesting so that's my excuse to ask
that question to follow up on that a
little is there anything about your
experience working on season one that
let you walk away with a new tool new
lesson that now you plan to apply to
season two going forward just that I I
think this show is all about tone uh and
it's all about the girls together in the
certain register they're able to live in
when they're interacting with each other
when they're bringing themselves to the
characters and I think the more we can
feed into that into their relationships
with one another because I think this
ultimately is kind of a love letter to
their friendship that's that's home for
us you know the time travel all the
other exciting Adventures it matters and
its Story by the end of the day we
really care about these girls in their
journey and when we're writing that when
we're performing that and we're seeing
that I think we're really doing paper
girls right you were very very
successful that is one of my favorite
qualities of the series you made just so
it's on camera I'm going to say this one
last thing to you Brian it's not a
question it's just a statement why the
last man deserved to run on and on you
did exceptional work with that you did
exceptional work here seriously
everybody out there make sure you watch
paper girls thank you guys for your time
thank you